[Music]
I'd like to talk about Google's
autocomplete feature for example if all
you do is type the word is the third
result that comes up reads is Daniel
Tosh gay this is what the world needs an
answer to let it go my little monsters
what else you guys are searching for
let's see if I type in is it bad if here
are the top two things that come up is
it bad if your poop floats and is that
bad if your poop is green the answer is
no to both it's only bad if your poop is
black or there's blood in it or it's on
your chest let's see what happens if you
type in do BL apparently you guys are
wondering if blind people dream yes they
do but they prefer not to because when
they wake up it's really depressing
here's what happens when you type in can
you the third most popular question is
can you get pregnant from pre-cum
the answer that is the big yes of all
the forms have come pre is the most
potent and the ten yeast if you type in
were there here's what comes up were
there black people on the Titanic yes
we're their white slaves I hope not any
gay presidents probably were there ever
dragons what is wrong with this country
those are all really good questions now
let's try doing this with Google Images
if you type in 'probably smells bad what
do you think the first picture that
comes up is did you guess Rihanna I'd
like to get her stank all over me if you
type in must be stopped the third result
is the band train and they haven't been
have they they are still churning out
one adult contemporary hit after another
hey if you type in handsome comedians
you get 34 pages of results and I'm not
on a single one of them that's horseshit
maybe I need to get more specific with
my search if you type in sexy white
comedians named Daniel I'm fourth
so in conclusion Google is garbage and
I'm taking my business to Bing